this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman all right
let's make fun of some people for the
segue we call [ __ ] that should not be
[Music]
usually [ __ ] that usually [ __ ] that
should not be as a video clip it's a
movie or TV show where somebody [ __ ]
up and they left something on the screen
that they shouldn't have left on what
happened
you said usually was it's alright it's
okay set indominus i thought you're
gonna be like but tonight I shoot my
heart nerd in the head this week it's a
still photograph because this made the
news this week and I thought there was
absolutely [ __ ] that should not be so we
should talk about it okay
familiar with the TV show Downton Abbey
me neither
no one watches that [ __ ] show I don't
say oh it's such a great show oh love
Johnny what [ __ ] you nobody watches that
show everybody says they watch the show
but nobody [ __ ] watches it I know one
guy that watched it who Jason Mewes news
watch isn't chasing me is not only
watches it but it's current on it and
[ __ ] his butt trying to get me to
watch it fall it's the last person I
would have guessed watching Downton
Abbey amazing he's just like you don't
get it they serve people they live in to
house you know I'm like I think I do get
it I think you explained it quite well
it's like but it's olden times well no
one loves the British class system of
the 1920s we all know that so they're
coming up on a new season they sent out
a promotional photo this week of Hugh
Bonneville and Laura Carmichael two of
the actors they put it up everywhere
much to their chagrin because of the
[ __ ] that shouldn't I be this is in
three stages let's let's put up the
first the photo and see if you can spot
the [ __ ] that should not be there
there's the photo that's the big one now
let's go to the next picture we'll help
you out a little bit it's on the mantle
the [ __ ] that should not be now let's
zoom in a little bit yeah [ __ ] water
bottle is on the mantle at Downton Abbey
sadly plastic water bottles wouldn't be
invented for another [ __ ] 40 years
that [ __ ] that should not be right there
so they've announced literally on the
set they're banning all water bottles
from the set no one can drink water out
of a bottle any more on that set be
clean cancer somebody is [ __ ] pissed
off and also no underwear makes me want
to watch the show for the first time now
you know they're going commando Muse
never told me these like it's all Bush
seriously though no wonder we're into
the costumes because they're afraid
someone might you might bend over or
something and somebody might see
something so no underwear wouldn't it be
worse if they saw something with no
underwear
well they had vaginas back then I didn't
have with Spanx look at Jason Mewes
[ __ ] texting me going did you know
they had vaginas in the twenties
[Music]
you